de la lumière rouge pour favoriser le
sommeil c'est ce que prétend
l'entreprise illate sleep qui affirme
que ces lumières permettent de dormir
plus profondément un de ces arguments de
vente des études scientifiques on s'est
penché là-dessus je fais partie des 20
000 Québécois qui dorment mieux grâce à
une entreprise d'ici
c'est un appareil breveté d'aide au
sommeil inspiré par la NASA devant des
promesses aussi à l'échange
l'insomniaque est prête à tout essayer
la finalité c'est que je veux dormir je
veux connaître qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une nuit de sommeil profonde ce que
je connais pas
[Musique]
Yves de rosby a des problèmes de sommeil
depuis son jeune âge
grutier de profession il a travaillé de
nuit une bonne partie de sa vie j'ai
jamais été capable de récupérer tout ça
depuis ce temps là donc j'ai eu des
difficultés ce sont accumulées je dors
pas j'ai une nuit de sommeil environ de
5 à 6 heures par nuit sa conjointe Marie
el Thériault s'inquiètent pour sa santé
elle s'est dit que le yeelight pourrait
peut-être aider c'est une publicité que
j'ai vu à la télévision alors là j'en ai
parlé à Yves j'ai dit peut-être que pour
toi ça serait une solution
nous lui avons proposé d'essayer le
produit là je me dis je peux fermer à
essayer des choses pour voir si ça peut
m'aider
est une invention pour l'aide au sommeil
breveté en France l'appareil créé au
Québec est vendu près de 140 dollars sur
facebook l'humoriste Jérémy Demay
explique comment il fonctionne
le HiLight va émettre une lumière rouge
une longueur d'onde pure calibrée à
exactement 630 nanomètres pendant 14
minutes alors les cellules derrière tes
yeux vont capter cette longueur d'onde
et favoriser la production de mélatonine
[Musique]
fait plusieurs affirmations endormi vous
plus rapidement dormez mieux dormez plus
profondément et il est inspiré par la
NASA
l'entreprise dit s'appuyer sur des
études scientifiques dont une qui selon
Elite démontre que la lumière rouge
favorise la production de mélatonine
l'hormone du sommeil
deux de ses études proviennent de la
spécialiste du sommeil américain Mariana
figero qui ne comprend pas pourquoi il a
été cite ses études
prix et étonné par cette réponse nous
sommes allés à leur boutique de Montréal
munie d'une caméra cachée laventeuse qui
est aussi propriétaire va beaucoup plus
loin que les affirmations du site web
des light entre autres sur le nombre
d'études sur la lumière rouge sur la
lumière rouge j'ai un outil 4000
mais selon les experts que nous avons
consulté on est loin de milliers
d'études sur la lumière rouge et le
sommeil
selon Véronique Danon chercheur à la
clinique du sommeil de l'hôpital du
sacré-cœur de Montréal celle qui existe
sont peu convaincantes pour les études
qui ont montré des effets de la lumière
rouge sur le sommeil ces études le
comportent très peu de sujets et ils ont
principalement regardé des mesures
subjectives du sommeil une mesure
subjective est une auto-évaluation du
patient avec un questionnaire une mesure
objective permet de mesurer la durée des
différentes phases du sommeil à l'aide
électro
c'est basé sur des études de la NASA
la NASA n'a pourtant publié aucune étude
faisant référence à une lumière qui a la
même longueur d'onde que les lights
selon les spécialistes que nous avons
consulté nous avons écrit un chercheur
Robert Soler qui a travaillé sur
l'éclairage de la Station spatiale
internationale il nous répond que les
astronautes n'utilisent pas de lumière
rouge pour dormir
au coucher du soleil la longueur d'onde
dominante c'est celle là elle dit au
cerveau à c'est l'heure de relaxer et
c'est l'heure de favoriser la production
de mélatonine et même l'accélérer c'est
toutes des choses qui sont améliorées
grâce aux lettres
la chercheuse Véronique danou affirme au
contraire que ces liens ne sont pas
démontrées on a quelques études menées
chez un petit nombre de sujets qui vont
montrer des augmentations de mélatonine
suite à la lumière rouge mais on n'a pas
de d'augmentation de la durée du sommeil
on n'a pas ses études-là pour le moment
les études ne démontrent tout simplement
pas que la lumière rouge est efficace ce
n'est pas prouver que l'exposition la
lumière rouge va avoir un impact sur ces
mesures objectives du sommeil il n'y a
pas de consensus scientifique non plus
que d'études cliniques qui démontrent
l'efficacité de la lumière rouge sur la
qualité et la quantité de sommeil l'un
des inventeurs du ylight et pourtant un
chercheur sur le sommeil Claude gonflier
du centre de recherche en neurosciences
de liant difficile donc de s'y retrouver
pour les consommateurs ce que je pense
ça arrive souvent maintenant surtout par
sur un article pour être intéressé
souvent c'est ça c'est que on prétend
que c'est
colorés par des scientifiques colorés
par des toutes sortes de tests il y a
personne qui peut autrement dit
contester ça facilement les dirigeants
des light Bonnier et Jasmine Lebeau ont
accepté de nous rencontrer aux affirmez
que on dort mieux on dort plus
profondément on dort plus rapidement
avec highlight vous êtes basés sur quoi
basé sur deux choses dans un premier
temps le retour des clients mais ça on
savait pas avant de faire l'appareil
n'est-ce pas donc c'est surtout les
études donc lorsque la sens fait monte
pas comme tel que la lumière rouge aide
au sommeil c'est pas démontré
scientifiquement pas encore peut-être
de chiffres c'est assez entendre quand
vous vendez votre produit que c'est
appuyé par la science l'est quand même
on s'est basé sur tout ça pour arriver à
ces paramètres là pour vous ça
fonctionne oui ça
il soutiennent que les 4000 études
auxquelles il faisait référence lors de
notre visite à leur bureau portait sur
la lumière rouge en général que je
pourrais faire c'est vous pointer vers
justement Olivier Casel puis le docteur
gonfier nous les avons joints Claude
grand fier nous écrit en tant que
scientifique il ne peut pas se prononcer
sur l'effet de la lumière rouge produite
par leur système sur le sommeil et que
nous avons besoin de plus d'études bien
menées chez l'humain de son côté Olivier
cazel reconnaît lui aussi qu'il n'y a
pas d'études probante sur les bienfaits
de la lumière rouge sur le sommeil il y
a pas de base scientifique sérieuse là
je vous rejoins mais à la 200% par
contre quand il a fait essayer le illite
à une cinquantaine de personnes de son
entourage il a obtenu une majorité de
commentaires favorables je dis
que toutes mes recherches que je
continue à faire me montre qu'il y a
certainement un truc avec la lumière
mais bien sûr qu'il faut des études je
suis le premier à vous le dire dans les
faits pour mieux dormir la science
indique plutôt qu'il faut diminuer notre
exposition à la lumière surtout à la
lumière bleue les recommandations
internationales sont claires 30 minutes
avant le coucher on sort les écrans des
chambres à coucher puis on s'éloigne le
plus possible de la lumière quant aux
deux comédiens des publicités de ylight
Richard Turcotte nous affirme qu'il est
satisfait du produit et Jérémie Demay
n'a pas répondu à nos questions bonjour
bonjour ça fait trois semaines que vous
avez l'highlight en votre possession ça
fait trois semaines vous l'essayer
nous sommes retournés rencontrés
monsieur de rosby pour savoir s'il fait
partie des nombreux clients satisfaits à
légués par la compagnie est-ce que ça
fonctionne ou ça fonctionne pas
[Musique]
retiré de son site internet les études
de la scientifique américaine Mariana
Figaro et d'ailleurs selon le centre de
contrôle et de prévention de la maladie
des États-Unis la lumière rouge n'a
aucun effet sur le cycle du sommeil